I waited for today what happened bro
what did they do to you
why would anyone cut you in pieces good
that was it Ellis the file no I don't
trust you it's impossible
the father wouldn't answer okay wasn't
safar I'm sorry I did oh no we're out of
oil all right I don't even know all
right what is this
I guess there's got to be some way to
progress I'm still kind of sick by the
way ma'am okay then hey what is the
house what is death
where's it coming from all right Oh Judy
I can't pick that I couldn't think man
yes girls but I got that was fun
all right he's not there chair motor
activated camera actor more charitable
all right all right fine
anyway this Jam is a tango but all I
need a hammer
I get it I need a hammer chicas crisis
scare me all right I have to another box
now where's the hammer I need this
helmet down they were that is Bauhaus
Jesus Christ what this audience in me
stop this what it's happening again
no no I'm to the barrels nah nah it gets
like there Jesus Christ I don't trust
this guitar to my house slave now all
right ah that's picking up I'm home
Petey Petey Petey listen to me I can
help you I'm so pumped I know you're
scared no you need a hammer
hey what you got a dildo for me get show
me show me now show all right
fine we need to find a hammer Jennifer
hoppity no no Jennifer Lee I'm sorry
what someone say I forgot the key I
don't don't see a key I don't almost
wrong love lucky huh maybe here I don't
know I don't know hey I just forget a
key god damn it you found the key
I don't touching each other hey I'm home
I'm so found look at me oh it's blue on
blue I'm punk time I die I'm honorbound
on
right that's up there let's continue
forward let's continue for the good no
though I just want to shake holy [ __ ]
there's almost 6000 that's amazing you
bros are awesome I love y'all so much
after this I'll just do it a little Q&A
I thought it could be fun okay focus but
hey mr. Shea how are you doing here
Peter you forgot the key I was gonna
tell you g scratch can't just go without
a key geez alright alright you had the
key I don't have a key don't look at me
why should I keep the keys here to the I
machine alright maybe here nope nope it
wasn't there wait I don't wanna shake
that door yeah that I am hi Columba I
can't do any force because I'm still
sick I'm sorry what is this
ah a little box I love them tonight
welcome to your room please
my room would not look like that usually
have some drinks and books for you you
need to check the word drink that is
something behind what what what there's
nothing behind me what what what why you
so fat Ian a pity I love you disguise
your fat get out of my way blocking my
insanity potion that's appreciated
there's gotta be something in here
inside a freakin No look behind you
hello pity hello jeez ah Jennifer I'm
trying to focus
where's the hammer does anyone know
where the hammer is I don't wanna fall
and where's the filer that's a bigger
clue
hey it's my house this is my room I
should keep her have her of course I
have a torture chamber in my room that's
coffee oh yes I'll be whatever let's try
that note again welcome to your room
reading you have some things and books
for you you need to check the word drink
there is something behind
oh hey madam ah okay hey I should have
read more carefully
all right I'm an idiot that's so special
but we have a key
it's fine fine no harm done I'm happy
are you happy I'm happy
mmm okay there's another room I get it I
get it I should listen to purity
I mean piggy white as a pea all right
let's continue what are you doing here I
told you this is my house no battles are
allowed okay just calm down I know you
piss off hey wait wait this if this
works I'm gonna wet myself I'm so Pompey
now I never like Superbad I'm sorry
if you
all right let's go here oh we should
penis everywhere not about the naked
guys but they're doing it I hate
telepathic naked guys I'll deal with
this one pt I'll deal with this one
mm-hmm
I'll tell him cos he's gonna be alright
I'll just leave me with him well I'll
show pictures gonna show the telephone
naked guy not to mess with me yeah I'm
home
teleporting yelling no not my bad I'm
not gay even though I'm naked constantly
nah there we go
that's BAM say my name alright I'm a
charge in my hammer rap yeah that's what
I'm talking about
another key yes share my company
happening happy [ __ ] skies so many miss
yeah over 6000 people that's amazing I'm
so glad you bros are here alright let's
continue 6000 say I'm that oh my god
really
you bros are friggin crazy I love you
wrote so much
I'm just so glad you he I don't even
know anymore
somebody broke can you feel that bro
love to know I'll shoot a missile in the
miles on nothing body hey I caught it
ice I don't trust corridors
not one day [ __ ] I don't have any oil
all right
let's just take it easy peel lemon
squeeze I don't trust this place I was
pretty I am golden edition fathanah
where will you be out where were you
before I'm sorry I was busy blocking
these barrels they were trying to stop
you all right that makes sense
it's really I think you must keep the
funnel with you for this area oh god oh
god boughs what are you planning
don't just be quiet and pretend you
don't expect anything now follow this
way building alright so father so I
heard you have 6,000 rows here that's
amazing alright let's go in here even
though I don't trust this place very
much
be careful video all right Wow just I
know you want to kill them but B just
focus pity so I guess I remember the
brows are watching past I hate you
alright alright alright mr. cherrick
please [ __ ] alright I guess there's
nothing in here hey what about the what
what's wrong Shyvana like were you
scared no I wasn't scared I'm not a scav
this cries I'm so far oh oh god I don't
trust this place don't want a pity I am
actually an expert at wait wait I need
is the closer Stephane ah meaning the
closer I understand I am actually a next
stop at deciding whether or not they are
safe let me look
it's safe Billy hey was right obscure
that was ID what are you expecting
something here no of course not all
right let's pick this up in the mouth Oh
cow how I miss kau crater uh nothing
here really that's surprising
all right fine let's go here hey this
place is good I like your place you got
a piano it's very laid out hello Eagle
haha I don't know why you would talk to
Eagles Jesus Christ I sometimes I think
you're crazy pity okay just let me down
normally that's nothing jaesik all right
fine I'm breakdancing all right let's go
I'm so sorry come on I was just kidding
all right
oh just that in here get out of here all
right thanks for father let's go in here
I don't like this area very much okay
let's go in here mm-hmm what are you
doing you can't you can't just say that
you're not interested
don't like look at that very interesting
payday I'm awkwardly close to biggest
bat
hey you don't like that you're like my
buddy I mean there's a lot of people who
die for this block you know a lot of
people would just want to put their face
right in there and just know are you
crazy
put a paper geek can we please go what
are you talking about
we're just getting started I'm just ah
okay uh let's continue can you sell on
the gas without breaking his funnel
awesome thank you okay let's see here
does anyone know how long this map is
I'm kind of curious okay all right let's
go down here
hey it was like in here like a second
ago all right fine let's just go down
again I guess I guess oh yeah I know I
miss the room so let's go back and check
the trunk down yi apart what are you
doing you're not piggy Jesus Christ
focus really you have people watching
your life you know you haven't a
reputation to protect
all right which way all right are you
bros with me Oh hola - laughs stuff oh
wait I'm confused
Gingka Lana goth gopher Lana pink planet
Oh Tula Daffy I like this way today
all right and then here fine mmmn trusts
play hey naked people dot please Wow
what are you doing pity Jesus Christ
I've got so many dead people something
bad happened here or good depends if you
like that kind of stuff I'm just saying
I don't know sorry I don't know what
Alice I know he feels weird I just like
you can't see me I'm not used to having
my the orchid is near and then ground -
what the orchid is near brow and the
grantor but I think you already seen
them I hope it was funny bro forever
Martin you will never look dim no trail
it
[Music]
Party City I'm proud of it I thank you
mr. Sharon hey Daffy golf I am here I'm
Stefano it's father finish this yeah